[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
focus on a guy by the name of Tom Segura
comedy fans uh certainly might know of
him he's a comedian he's an author and a
podcaster and it's in that podcasting
role that we're kind of focused on this
morning after a segor shared some pretty
colorful opinions on our home City yeah
about Erie on a recent episode of his
own podcast called two bears one cave
take
a look I hate Erie Pennsylvania
a bunch of losers it's a depressed town
with a depressed economy and if you live
there you know zero yeah
I didn't find it funny at all uh Erie is
a wonderful place to live I feel blessed
I've lived here my whole life was born
and raised here I love it everybody in
my family loves it and everybody I work
with it loves it Bill Burr verse Philly
Joe Rogan vs Connecticut Tom Segura
against the entire state of Louisiana as
long as stand-up comedies existed so too
as comedians getting involved with an
ongoing beef against a specific city or
town well it's now time to add Tom
Segura vs Erie Pennsylvania to the top
of that list for those of you who watch
the latest ymh live show you know about
the Erie weatherman who's been going
head-to-head with your mom's house fans
on Twitter ever since Tom mentioned his
love for their City on an episode of two
bears one cave back in September you
always stood on Connecticut the dumbest
place in the country it's not a real
State it's a highway between Boston and
New York and it's filled with people
that have no hope
holy [ __ ] they have no hope I've never
heard somebody go harder on Connecticut
well I grew up in Massachusetts yeah so
I worked in Connecticut all the time and
every time I'd leave I'd be like what
the [ __ ] I'll tell you this though I did
Mohegan Sun Arena and it was a [ __ ]
blast yeah
mostly people from New York a lot of
mass people yeah there you go that makes
sense yeah yeah the Connecticut people
are probably like what's everybody
laughing at
one of my best friends Tommy Jr he still
lives there yeah he's been I've been
friends with her for 30 years he's from
there yeah I'll [ __ ] on him every time I
call him up it's so fun to [ __ ] on a
plate I mean like I hate Erie
Pennsylvania so much Erie Pennsylvania
such a [ __ ] dump a bunch of losers
it's a depressed town with a depressed
economy and if you live there you know
you're a [ __ ] zero yeah
just get out get out but if you're
[ __ ] born in a place like that you're
doomed after this episode his rant was
played on the local Erie news and they
even interviewed their mayor about Tom's
comments this should have been the end
of it all they got to play a segment on
their local news show about famous
comedian talking about their City it was
all pretty much over until one of their
local weathermen decided that he should
use his social media reach and clever
brain to attack a world famous top tier
comedian in a battle of jokes I should
mention this clip is from ymh live which
normally I would not show a clip from a
pay-per-view show but this doesn't spoil
any of their sketches or heavy segment
and really has nothing to do with their
live show it's just to tell this story
so I feel like this is okay and then
there was this there was a moment where
this [ __ ] dork uh that does the
weather chimed in he tried to a David
Walter uh this guy's tough to describe
our home in good conditions this morning
at least when you take a look at what's
coming down out the door it's a mess out
there I heard for Tom the reason he's so
mad is because he wasn't voted in the
top 10 of the sexiest bald men alive
that's what I'm here yeah
then he got a couple I guess he got a
couple of crew guys to go like ah like
that sick burn Walter so I want to be
clear we didn't set we didn't say like
find him or do anything the people on
their own a small group of people that's
gonna grow significantly uh
decided to pester him a bit you know
yeah yeah they did it on Instagram and
on Twitter and then he has been like
he's like oh I'll get him because you
know he he feels like he's sassy and
funny so he started doing his own he
started to do [ __ ] like uh what did he
do here to those who followed me because
of the weather you might be noticing a
lot of weird comments on my posts it's a
apparently result of uh Tom hates Erie
PA I made a funny comment about Tom and
word got out his fan base so now they're
swarming my social media accounts with a
bunch of sayings they were comical for
20. so he got sick of it immediately
yeah which is why it's gonna be so much
funnier when this really happens to you
um yeah that's just the beginning oh
yeah it was first pass yeah this is
gonna get interesting
um [ __ ] you're done buddy but then he
tried to like he you know you could tell
he's it's like the guy in it's like the
office like when you meet somebody who
like thinks they're yeah really funny
they're the funny guy okay and so oh he
starts to he started wait right wait can
you go back I'm sorry just before I do
this yeah here's my favorite part of
this if you have a legit weather
question just DM me and I will answer it
please don't post in the comments who
the [ __ ] has a legit weather question
I'm I'm glad anybody [ __ ] care well
I'm glad you mentioned that because I
have a feeling he's gonna be getting a
lot of liquids
you're possible and I was don't DM him
just go ahead and put it in the comments
um
legit questions only though legit
weather questions and uh that he is it's
funny that he actually uses a meme from
the office all right he should be on the
show so
she tried to have fun after he goes like
hey guys I know where the bodies are
right and then he goes and then this is
like the ultimate uh like dork
Zinger is like you're in the basement
you know like are you are you riding
things in your mom's basement yeah so
he's like oh you're at your mom's house
in the basement where most of you
probably live so now he's trying to give
it to the fans that they're they're
basement dwellers you know sure
um I do I do feel kind of honored that
I'm at the same level as Garth you're
not
um
uh and then oh then his hashtag Thompson
basement dweller so he keeps referring
to fans as as basement people uh 100
chance that the Thompson grow up
basement Club will be spitting wasps
through the fence of my social media
spitting wasps through the fence also
100 chance it will not snow here hey
spitting wasps and then he he keeps
going to basement right so he's like
no that Toms are a basement Club the
walk up to your parents rent free
kitchen so he's basically saying that
the fans are all out of work you know
losers right and that's it but like
Dairy here's the thing you're gonna get
a wide variety of people
some of them might be out of work but
some of them won't be I promise
and then his latest thing is that he's
like oh he's like I decided to instead
of being because he was like bring me on
the show oh please now he says he wants
to play basketball and that he'll wear
jeans and then it'll be total
Destruction by me I'll tell you this
right now you're invited I will play you
one-on-one in basketball
but we will be miked
and there'll be cameras there just so
you know
and and the invitation is open so if you
want to come down to Austin and play
basketball but there are no direct
flights from Erie to Austin [ __ ] no
there's direct flight no no no you'll
have to start the train now and then a
few buses and then maybe around and he's
trying to get on the show okay he's like
he's like put me on the show
here it is man serious weather questions
only whole new season of social media is
going to happen and you're it's it's not
winter it's uh it's basement time so
have fun some might be surprised to know
that this view didn't start on the ymh
live it didn't even start on the two
bears one Cave episode with Rogan the
Tom Segura vs Erie Pennsylvania Saga
goes all the way back to the beginning
of Tom's stand-up career when he was
performing in Erie at a club named
juniors are there any uh cities or clubs
never again oh yeah yeah here we go
Wuhan
uh I don't want to go to Erie
um oh I died in Erie
that's a clean room isn't it they want
you to be clean Jokers Juniors Juniors
last laugh yeah that was it I did it
once and the guy was like you got to be
clean I'm talking squeaky and he hosted
he went up and he's like so I was
[ __ ] my son in the ass
he didn't have to be clean that that guy
was they were [ __ ] it was because of
they sold it though so it's not the same
owners now okay so that clean thing came
from this woman who bought the club her
husband would work the bar and and he
would like police out you got to be
clean you're like you guys have said
it's like eight times man yeah and then
I remember I did a set where I worked
clean I did a clean 45 or whatever it
was then and then when I got off stage
the lady goes did you say penis oh my
God I go what she goes one of the
servers said that you said penis I go
isn't that the proper way to describe
the anatomy And she was like I guess
like that now wow wow I guess
I mean it was just a nightmare the
funniest part of this whole situation to
me personally is the fact that on the
live show Tom and Christina didn't bring
up this weatherman thing until about
minute nine or ten of the show and
within the hour their loyal ymh fan base
had turned his Instagram account private
they literally flooded all of his social
media to the point where he had to
change his account to private and he's a
weatherman he's trying to give people
news
[Music]
you need freeze pipe simple as that I
know what to tell you buddy the biggest
clouds the coldest smoke the smoothest
experience that's Breeze bite okay if
you enjoy smoking cannabis or CBD but
you hate that throat and lung burning
then you gotta check out today's sponsor
free Spike this thing right here simple
as that the secret is freezable glycerin
Chambers this thing Frozen so I have two
options for you we have the freeze pipe
bubbler Pro kit smaller more compact
easier perhaps but not as fun as I'm
talking about my first wife
smaller compact easier for Deborah
I always hated that [ __ ] name she was
like call me Deb
the freezepipe.com that's the
freezepipe.com pipes bubblers Bombs all
got it I'm sick and the only cure is to
bring me my freeze pie
the main mommies are truly the best fan
base in all of Comedy I don't even think
there's any arguing that at this point
and I know there's some watching right
now so I just want to say shout out to
you guys keeping it high and tight
following Proto make sure you subscribe
to joke world right now to stay in the
comedy loop it's basically like
SportsCenter for people that love comedy
thank you again for watching this video
and I'll be back Monday with the comedy
news
foreign
[Music]